متاعب الصين مع وباء كوبي 19 لا تنتهي هنا
في شنغهاي التي تعد العاصمه الاقتصاديه
للصين واكثر مدنها بالسكان تعمل مراكز
اجراء اختبارات الاصابه بالفايروس دون
توقف في حين ترزحوا المستشفيات تحت وطاه
ضغوط كبيره من جراء طفره الاصابات بعد
قرار السلطات الصينيه رفع غالبيه تدابير
الحجر والاغلاق كما كشفت محارق الجثث في
البلاد انها تواجه صعوبات في التعامل مع
زياده اعداد الجثامين من ضحايا الفيروس
المركز الصيني لمكافحه الامراض والوقايه
منها اعتبر ان تحديد مستوى الاصابات امر
صعب خاصه بعد انتهاء العمل بسياسه صفر
الاتجاه العام لتحولات يتعلق بشكل اساسي
بالهروب المناعيه الذي يجعله اكثر عدوى
بين الاشخاص حتى لو لم تزداد قدرته على
الانتقال فان مزاياه في الانتقال ستزداد
القطاع اللوجستيه الصحي في الصين يدق جرس
التعبئه من خلال اعطاء الاولويه لتمويل
مقاطعات البلاد بالادويه المضاده لاعراض
الاصابه بكوفيت 19
ومضادات الزكام والحمى بالاضافه الى
اختباره الفحوص والكمامات الطبيه في مشهد
يوحي بان البلاد تستعد لموجه اصابات كبيره
في مواجهه دائمه مع وباء طال اماده